so one explanation that people have put
forward over the years for these spooky
connections and for quantum mechanics
actually in general is that it's an
indication we live in a multiverse in
other words that there are other domains
of reality out there that we have only a
very dim glimpse of quantum mechanics
says that when I measure a particle I
get a random result and doesn't have any
explanation with that random result so
if I flip a quantum coin it comes out
heads or tails and I see heads now the
strange thing is the mathematics says I
should see heads and tails so it's
always been the mystery of why I see one
or the other the proposition is that
actually that the coin does come up
heads and tails but it comes up heads in
our universe in tails in another
universe so the idea of different
universes of parallel universes is a way
to make sense of kind of the
multiplicity the outcomes that are
observed in quantum mechanics and people
have proposed this would be a way to
actually kind of get rid of the
nonlocality that the nonlocality the
spooky action at a distance is actually
our kind of imperfect glimpse of a
multiverse of parallel universes and
that individually those universes all
behave completely locally no spooky
action and I kind of actually have a lot
of sympathy for that position actually
it's kind of awesome to think that there
might be parallel universes not just out
there but actually in here that we could
be kind of just cheek-by-jowl with
parallel universes all the time and we'd
never even sense them that any
measurement we make would cause the
University of branch parallel universes
to just be conjured up all the time and
it's kind of an amazing kind of
conception of nature but I've kind of
gone off the idea as much as I kind of
I'm drawn to it initially and the the
reason is that I think that when you see
these spooky actions in normal County in
a broader context for instance in the
context of other places where they occur
in nature not just for the particles but
they also soon to occur for black holes
it seemed to happen in cosmology they
seem to happen in the workings of
gravity there's a variety of contexts in
which you see spooky actions
and those other contexts are harder to
explain in this kind of parallel
universe scenario but what they really
seem to point to is that space and time
are derivative the real message of the
spooky action is is that space and time
are not fundamental the particles are
rooted in that deeper layer where space
and time don't yet exist and that's the
way to explain them so the building
blocks of the world may not be tiny
things what could these building blocks
be if they're not tiny because that's
kind of what we think of as a building
block a Lego is smaller than the thing
you built out of the Legos they may be
in what seems to us enormous things
things that spend the entire universe
and they're somehow acting in concert
with one another to produce these these
phenomena of space